a lone palm tree among rows of dusty
buildings trees and plants in general
are rare here making shade a luxury in
the Mauritanian capital new act shot
those seeking respite from the beating
Sun have no choice but to huddle in the
thin shadows cast by buildings but
that's all about to change
at least in this street a group of local
young people are set on completely
redesigning it they've developed a model
for the street as they foresee it make
the city green as a project run by the
city's cultural center together with a
German development agency we've
suggested planting trees on the streets
they'll provide shade but if we put
benches around them they'll also provide
a place for school pupils to hang out
together we're also discussing a
possible ban on cars driving down the
road how are you city CR us well you
know the problem is that people here
chop down trees for their animals which
isn't good there's a lack of
understanding here that trees and plants
are important for the climate the
council needs to start doing its bit to
clearing away the rubbish and spreading
awareness about the issue without Envia
instead damage WI a new Act has many
other problems to deal with the city is
built on a salt flood large parts of it
are below sea level and when it rains
here it pours
turning the dusty ground into a huge
lake and streets into rivers our main
concern used to be siltation
but since 2009 because of climate change
water itself has become an issue we've
had flooding here that's covered 80% of
the city water is now our biggest
problem in the pre verdict our key
entity impactive
the young activists have collected
photos documenting the flooding mixed up
with trash and sewage it's a breeding
ground for disease heavy rains are
becoming more common here and pushing up
groundwater levels the water literally
gushes up from below into the city and
there's another threat to Newark shot
along the Atlantic coast close to the
city for years the German development
agency GI Z has been working with local
NGOs to try and curb this homegrown
problem bus here I'm probably missed as
many as large amounts of sand have been
removed for use in construction work new
a chart has expanded massively in recent
years it's only really existed since
1958 and back then it had a population
of just 500 today it's 1 million which
has meant a lot of sand being removed
for building work that's created gaps
and the dunes and leveled them so those
that we still have need to be stabilized
if your pardon
tamarisk bushes have now been planted on
50 hectares of dunes they're extremely
tough unable to cope with the salty
water and a lack of nutrients in the
sandy ground their job is to reinforce
the dunes and protect Newark shot from
the dangers of rising sea levels